dane dunnig on the mound this will be
his 21st start of the season overall
respectable numbers has been 11 days
since he has started dunning's 2-2
and that's a beauty strike three called
and he gets lowry looking cole irvin
looking for his ninth win of the year
settle in against this rangers lineup
oh two pitch and that one's lined out to
right field it drops in base hit
isaiah continues to swing the good bat
for the rangers he has been their best
hitter
he's a threat to go culverson goes after
the first pitch and this one lofted to
center drops in base hit and then it's
bobbled out there briefly and kinder
fulfills good speed will get him to
third so aggressive base running after
that little miscue by marty the error
by marty may have opened up an
opportunity a bouncer up the middle and
that one gets by
lowry mishandled it a run scores
culverson to third on the
well i don't know if it debates it or
not
for garcia but it's one nothing rangers
ninth pitch of the at-bat and this one
is up the middle that's a base hit
culverson scores garcia with an
aggressive turn he heads to third
another base hit in the inning
and the rangers have a two-nothing lead
the 0-1 pitch a swing and that ball
driven into center field but martay is
right there shaded toward right center
he goes back to his left and hauls it in
tagging at third garcia he scores and
the rangers lead three nothing credit dj
peters with a sacrifice fly in his
seventh front vanity
will hold at one ball and two strikes as
gom swings and misses at the dunning
slider here's moreland coming off the
two homer game yesterday here's the 1-0
pitch and moreland it's a drive to left
center up the alley and nobody's there
and that's going to go to the wall for
esther jason by the time martin plays it
back that's a two-base hit for the
former ranger mitch moreland
there's a swing and a miss brown strikes
out
and the inning is done third strikeout
for donny we're going to see the debut
of johel pozzo here in the second first
pitch swinging he rolls one between
elvis andrews and jed lowry into left
center
well
no waiting around for johel pozzo the 24
year old native of venezuela has his
first big league hit he's pitched 17
innings against the rangers and giving
him eight earned runs he's got this one
he spins he fires the second for one on
the first and that's a double pluck
a raw prospect swings and misses out of
fastball and he's gone on strikes hit
total this year at 99 gonna get into
triple digits here on about half a
second
base hit
his second of the long game
it is really amazing that his ability to
be efficient when needed hard smash for
the shortstop area where culverson was
positioned and he makes a nice play
culverson good soft hands takes his time
good strong throw
over across the diamond nobody on
two outs the one two swinging them is
dunning with a strikeout in the pitch
that was nowhere near the strike zone
albania is headed to a force play his
first time up he swings and slams one
towards short and caught
by elvis or it caught him one or the
other it was a screaming line drive
right at him
makes the play and there's one out
and he chases that one that could change
up and that is the second strikeout for
reuben
just driving balls that way this one's
hit the other way and it's hit well and
it's gonna be off the top of the wall
chapman read it all the way he's racing
around third chapman's gonna come in and
he will score
so seth brown comes through to get the
a's on the board it's three to one so
chapman running from first and he's got
that play right in front of him he's
looking right at it and he read it
perfectly loved it loved this the ball
since off the bat he knew that ball is
going to get down in the gap
and there's a base in right field
here comes brown here comes the throw to
the plate and brown ends up holding up
so he got the late stop sign from mark
godzill and i think that was probably
the right thing to do
culverson quick throw
not in time run scores
culverson he made a really nice play but
marta is just too fast this is something
that doesn't necessarily go on the back
of a baseball card but really add value
to a ball club base is loaded after that
seven-pitch walk matt olson one-two
pitch
and he sends this one in the air out to
left field hanging up for quite some
time peters is back on the warning track
and
just enough room out there john gomes
leads it off for the a's in the sixth
they trail three two dennis santana's
pitches a line drive one hopper into
left for a base hit and passed the
diving backhanded fire the shortstop
kinder paleppa first seven years
of mitch moreland's big league career
were with the texas rangers so he
played a lot of baseball for the rangers
this one is driven to right going back
is garcia gets spinned around and it
bounces away from him and bounces toward
the right field line and that's going to
allow john gomez to come all the way
around and score and mitch moreland is
going to be at third with a stand-up
triple now we got to call him mitch
three bags now
wow well the ball hit that angled wall
deep right center field and it bounced
away from garcia and it just kept
rolling
that one has lined up the center field
base hit
moorland trots in to score and the a's
lead four to three
single triple single
to open up the top of the sixth inning
bouncer shortstop that could be two to
second there's one to go to first
falling down with a one hopper to first
and the inning is over
india bonies continues to impress us
with his athleticism
andy ibanez will lead it off as he
swings and hits one sharply to short and
it's off the glove of elvis and it
bleeds behind him into shallow left
center you know you're getting to live
your dream
this one shot up the middle by
martin his second hit of the ball game
and against the righties throws that
slider 80 percent of the time
oh first pitch swinging pozo hammers it
down
[Applause]
this one hung in the middle of the plate
and pozo knew the scattering report he
was ready for it and he unloaded so two
outs here's matt olsen these trailing
6-4
olson he smokes one to right center and
that baby is gone just over the wall a
line shot and that is home run number 29
for matt olson i mean i'm at a loss for
words kaife i mean that ball was squared
up
peters hits the ball hard deep to left
field it's gone
into the upper deck and
a two-run shot for dj peters
and he acts to the rangers lead that's
his first home run as a ranger yeah and
a big one
at first
[Applause]
brown a line shot headed for the right
field corner chapman digging for third
kat says gonna wave him home
here comes the throw to the plate and
it's not gonna be to the plate it's
gonna be back to second and they got
brown at second base so chapman does
come in to score to make it an eight to
six games
this one bounced right side could do it
good charge and flip to first and that
is it bartlett with his first big league
save and the rangers snap oakland's
seven game winning streak